[Musik]
und
hallo herzlich willkommen so verriet
will heute gibt einen ganz einfachen
geburtstagskuchen und zwar habe ich
einen schokokuchen gebacken
denkt ihr was menschen wirklich super
einfach denn erst ganz unspektakulär aus
aber im innern ist nur richtig große
überraschung und zwar ist es ein
implizites cache wenn wir mal den kuchen
anschneidet und wer gestern praktisch
ist dann kommt ein kleines maß stücke
raus und warum findet es so ich habe
zwei backformen alphabet von diesem
backformen gebacken und da packt man
praktisch zweiten hälfte setzte zusammen
und in diese vertiefungen her kommen
dann die smarties oder zum beispiel auch
eine leckere torten oder andere
überraschungen die ihr eben rein machen
möchtet ihr könnt das ganze natürlich
auch ohne diese spezielle backform
machen und einen eine google-plattform
nehmen und den am praktisch halbieren
und später ebenso kleine mulden
ausfüllen wenn natürlich ein bisschen
aufwendiger und wenn ihr sagt okay ich
mache das öfter und hat da ganz viele
rezeptideen verwies ich zum beispiel
dann lohnt sich das auf jeden fall
und deswegen starten wir gleich mal ich
zeige ich mach hier vorne die zutaten
für den teig brauche ich 250 gramm
butter + 50 vom zucker etwas von den
extrakt eine prise salz sechs eier 350
gramm mehl ein päckchen backpulver und
50 gramm pulver habe ich 200 vom joghurt
und etwas milch ernstlich der sintflut
harten ist dass wir alles in porto haben
das heißt ihr wisst ihr bak morgen
diesen kuchen dann stellt am besten
zutaten schon einfach vorher aus dem
kühlschrank heraus damit der rührteig
sich besser verbinden kann nämlich
zuerst einmal die butter aber ich habe
zeit auch verkehrsunfall zwischen zwei
stunden draußen stehen lassen aber
sollen auch die hauptsache alle haben
die gleiche temperatur nämlich die
butter die kommt in meiner rolle schüsse
da kommt der zucker mit dass so ein
extrakt was sonst
und etwas falsch und die zarten bleiben
jetzt in etwa drei bis vier minuten
cremig verrührt doch weist die kutter
masse dann schön luftig ist kommen jetzt
machen wir das so wenn wir waren jetzt
die eier minimal noch für kalte wird
ganz schlimm denn ich habe jetzt hier
auch ein bisschen warm - vorbereitet und
erfolgt jedoch immer schon wenn ihre
zeit machen bitte milch dazu geht dann
erwärmt sie immer dann habt ihr einfach
schön eine homogene mache ich jetzt
festgenommene wieder gleich wieder
homogen und ich kann in der zwischenzeit
schon bei mehl und backpulver zusammen
mittel und dann das 7
[Musik]
jetzt gebe ich die abwechslung die
mischung den joghurt und milch nicht zum
recyceln
[Musik]
diese zwei backformen und zwar ist die
eine die unterseite und andere die
oberseite von wie bereits schon erwähnt
und jetzt verspricht die mir etwas sagt
renzel geht eben am einfachsten vor
allem wenn man hier die serie drin hatte
kommt mit einem back pinsels macht nicht
so gut hin gibt zwar auch aber ist ein
bisschen es dauert ein bisschen länger
und natürlich jetzt den teig eine und
beim teig geb dir einfach so viel milch
mit das leben eigentlich ganz lustig
aber immer dickflüssiger teig entsteht
[Musik]
und wenn jetzt nur einen backofen hat
wie in jedem normalen haus als üblich
dann macht man westen droht dass wir
zuerst die gäste zubereitet kann eine
passform füllt und die backt und dann in
der zeit die andere hälfte
damit der teig einfach jetzt hier nicht
bei zimmertemperatur steht und die ganze
luft eben wieder entweicht und beck
kuchen wird an den vorräten backofen bei
190 grad ober unterhitze für etwa 35
minuten gebacken
der kuchen ist jetzt komplett abgekühlt
ich habe ihnen direkt nach dem backen
auf ein abkühlt liter gestürzt und dann
einfach mit einem vorbereitung abgedeckt
so trocknet er nämlich beim abkühlen
nicht aus jetzt hab ich hier 200 gramm
peter kolba töre ihr könnt zum beispiel
auch vollmilch oder auch weiße kuvertüre
nehmen wie die euch eben am besten
schmeckt und die habe ich bereits fein
gehackt und zwei drittel davon
hierüber einem warmen aber nicht
trockenen wasserbad verschmolzen
und jetzt kommt hier das restliche
drittel mit sein und das macht man aus
dem grund damit die kuvertüre temperiert
wird also dass wir später beim abkühlen
nicht diesen grauschleier bekommt und
damit die schokolade beim anschneiden
nicht so sein knackt oder auch einen
schönen glanz bekommt kommt etwas
kokosöl mit rein
[Musik]
das ist hier einfach kurz stehen bis die
chöre schon geschmolzen ist dann hat sie
die perfekte verarbeitung temperatur und
hier kann ich jetzt schon mal den kuchen
verarbeiten und zwar nehme ich zum
zusammenkleben einfach ein bisschen
marmelade und bestreicht jetzt hier die
ränder mit marmelade tierärzte räume
laden ohne stückchen
[Musik]
und in die vertiefungen gebe ich jetzt
martys rein weil sie schön bunt sind
aber ihr könnt ihr im 50 auch andere
süßigkeiten einzeln oder teufel auf eine
leckere creme ein land gehört eine
schokoladen danach egal was auch immer
immer stimmt schon wenn ich's marty
verschwunden
und jetzt kann ich das ganze mit der
ouvertüre über zingst und mit ein paar
streuseln bedecken
[Musik]
und damit die tortenplatte schön sauber
bleibt kommt einfach kopiert runter
[Musik]
und viertens geht gar nicht den coolen
seite stellen am besten ganz kurz in den
kühlschrank damit die couture festhalten
können sie schon an streit provoziere
sitzt und jetzt ist der moment da und
darf probieren
du warst als beim backen nicht dabei
lieber monats geschlossen
ich wollte eigentlich etwas erarbeiten
total verbindet jetzt müsse beachten und
zwar hat man ja diese kleinen herzchen
das heißt wenn er die überraschungen
gleich zum anschnitt sehen wollt müsst
ihr die herzen halbieren
wenn ihr aber möchte wie ich es bei
murat dass man die noch nicht seht dann
müsst ihr jetzt mit dem herzchen
schneiden
also moratti ein ganz normaler sauber
kochen ganz viel schokolade isst einfach
mal geht einfach super sagt ich auch
gern
[Musik]
hahaha tätigkeiten sprach entdeckt das
ist doch immer gewusst was kommt
naja ich hab mit kabarett in verbindung
gebracht aber immer kann wie gesagt an
dieser stelle nicht nur smarties
einfachen sondern auch eine leckere
creme zum beispiel an sicher an die
frauen machen also egal was man möchte
dabei ist eine einfache idee und ich bin
richtig gut vor allem für den
kindergeburtstag oder auch vielleicht
preis kohl oder und wie schmeckte der
kuchen
es freut mich also falls er dieses
rezept auch gerne nachmachen möchte dann
geht auch wenn ich - blog.de und ich
wünsche euch schon mal ganz schön spaß
machen ich werde mir auf jeden fall noch
eine andere reaktion mit der backform
ausdenken und freund der das nachmacht
dann schickt uns ein foto oder postet
einfach auf facebook oder bis zum
nächsten mal noch einmal machst du
einfach so nächsten für mich überraschen
innen und außen was fragen und schlecht
[Musik]